i'll use the lending money thing that i
got myself into
i knew it was a mistake
i felt it with every cell in my body
but i wanted to be the hero i wanted to
be the good guy
and
there was a dynamic in my family growing
up
where
you know it was like she's just like her
father she's just like her dad and my
dad was always the bad guy everybody
thought my dad was a bad guy now i've
gotten older and i'm like maybe he
wasn't the bad guy
after all um and it's interesting
because it actually brought me to find a
real
kind of healing with my dad but
i was
constantly trying to compensate and not
be the bad guy look i'm not the bad guy
look look i'm the hero look let me save
your day which never
worked and i did it over
and over and over again
um until
this last go-round where i made such a
massive mistake
playing it out and it backfired so badly
that i had to really look at myself and
be like all right i knew it once again
right trust you i knew not to do it why
did i do it because i wanted to be like
the hero the savior the good guy
why did i want to do that
and then it kind of comes back to that
sort of childhood ego state of like look
mom you know i'm i'm really a great kid
look at all the things look i share my
candy look i you know all that deep
[ __ ] that should have been worked
through and played out negatively
whereas
you know sometimes you have to learn the
hard way i am in therapy and i've
learned a lot from therapy i love
therapy you don't need to justify it in
any kind of way i have one or two
therapists at all times
it saved me from a lot of those mistakes
but some of them i end up having to make
the hard way i was like i've got to let
whatever is sitting on my chest with all
of this go and it's like the way they
say
um being angry
and holding a grudge is drinking poison
and hoping the other person dies
right and i used to hear it all the time
and be like yeah that's cute but like
i'm not jesus so that's that's a great
you know love your whole sounds good but
i'm just not that big of a person
and they couldn't figure out right if
something is antagonizing you actively
antagonizing you like if there's a wasp
stinging you on the arm how do you not
get pissed at that how do you know
and for some reason this this thing was
my back made everything else
seem like nothing
you're gonna do this and normally this
would drive me crazy and instead i was
like i don't even care i i i surrender
go do that do it i i you're the winner i
give up i surrender and i was able to
for the first time in my life realized
that
whatever
[ __ ] we hold on to
really i felt i felt the poison of
drinking it for the first time
and now i'm
99 of the time now
whatever it is and it did also help me
kind of reconnect with my dad after 30
years interesting
i was like life is way too short for
this [ __ ] man doesn't mean you can't
have boundaries you need you obviously
right like you have your boundaries
um but the bitterness and the anger
i try to let it just
when i finally let go of things wanting
to be a certain way wanting them to be a
certain way or expecting something
trying to make a difference
when i finally just accept things for
what they are where they're at and and
be at peace with that or at least they
just accept that it doesn't mean it's
peaceful it just means that it's just
the way it is um it's amazing how on the
other side of that
shift
they actually just start to change in
the way that i had always hoped it's
like the weirdest thing it's like we
hold on to this energetic imprint
with our opinion of them it almost like
re
it almost reinforces it yeah and it
perpetuates it and as soon as you let go
of that pattern then all of a sudden the
the patterns actually starts to change
within the other person
have you noticed that okay i just went
through this with my daughter
and
this kid broke me in half i'm serious no
one's officially broken me in half until
this kid this kid in conjunction with
technically i adopted my son but my ex
had him and
right because god if there is a god has
an amazing sense of humor it all
happened at the same time right um so
this kid is just very much like i do
what i
want and
you know some of those things i do what
i want
you know as a parent you're like oh [ __ ]
you know you you just it's like you do
real damage like things i can't undo for
you and the world is
very different place than
when i was a kid you know i do what i
want could be like i'm gonna experiment
with drugs well all right you might have
a bad night you might throw up all night
long but as long as you didn't get in
the car
you know what i mean no one died you'd
live now there could be a grain of
fentanyl on whatever the hell that is
and it's like you're dead it's over it's
finished it's not baby laxative in that
anymore dude it's it's like night night
you will die
she's not doing drugs she's very young
but my point is
some of these decisions some of these
things that they get into like on the
ipad and these group chats they're
they're life-ending like i think you
heard about that that 25 year old maybe
who worked for teen vogue
who was the editor in chief of team
bogan at 15 years old made it like a
racist or a homophobic tweet
15.
and they fired her canceled her
blackballed forever oh from 10 years
previous because now
this is it a girl or guy he or she is 25
working at the she's working at 25 years
old but now go back 15 years and they
found it and sort of basically like
ruined her life
it's like these things that like you
know or show
whatever she gets herself into
and finally i got to the place with this
kid where i was like okay
i've got you in a special program at
school we've got you you know
with a with a therapist we've got you
with a psychiatrist for atd like we've
got you with a tutor we've got like
and she still would like go blind and we
do that and i i looked at her one day
and i said listen
on my deathbed all i need to know from
my cell flu is that i dotted the eyes
and i crossed the t's and i did the best
that i could do for you and beyond this
you want to go around me you're going to
win
like you're working 24 7 to beat me and
you're going to win because i got to
sleep dude i got to live my life i got
to work like you're going to win
you want to go out of the house in this
outfit or you want to say something on
your ipad or you want to watch something
you got around you caught it on tv you
downloaded it you found a way like you
got on tick tock you you did all these
things you will win so whatever you do
to yourself
like i'm gonna do my best to make sure
you don't get physically hurt you don't
unintentionally hurt someone else
and that's and i'm gonna live with that
and i'm gonna be good with that dude and
it was oh danica i don't know what
happened but the minute i like kind of
gave up not on her but on trying to
control
you know what she saw what she did how
she you know all the tech
she the grades went from f's and d's to
a's and b's
and i i was like what
like and she you know she did something
she goes i wanted to do it mom
i [ __ ] up and i was like
and she's like i shouldn't have done it
i'm not gonna do it again and i was like
listen it's not that's not the we're not
i'm not the perfect mother
by any means and things are not going to
be perfect and i expect many more bumps
in the rude but you're right it was like
the minute i kind of was like
okay i don't feel guilty like i gave up
on you i don't feel like i there was
something i could have done and i didn't
do
and at this point like
yeah you still gotta try we're not
saying don't try but at some point in
time you have to know when to surrender
and know when to let go and i think
that's like a really hard lesson that
comes with time you can't you just can't
control everything you can't and it's
like it's that sort of omniscient desire
of like no no no i refuse to feel
helpless in the world like i i will
manhandle this i will make it what it
needs to be and the minute you realize
you actually can't you're not capable
that is that serenity prayer right of
like give me the courage to change the
things i can and you know the wisdom
whatever yeah
yes it's that combo it's that fine line
yeah and i think in my personal
relationships it's like all right
i don't want the regret
i'm gonna do what i think is right but
beyond that
at some point you have to let go you
have to you have no choice
what about i feel like this plays into
something that i'm really curious about
and i feel like you have a lot of
experience seeing this um
with
with you know clients is and people that
you've worked with but the effects of
trauma and emotional
baggage
and the body i just i kind of have a
little bit of a theory that um
some that are overweight that can't lose
weight
it's actually like an emotional
protection layer
associated with because i think a lot of
people and i'm grateful i'm not one of
them have dealt with a lot of
incest or rape or you know
being molested
and so i think there's a lot of
protection layers put on what what what
have you seen in in your time with
working with so many people that are
dealing with that that's so funny you've
brought up the two things that were so
in the kind of needling from my
my um my agent who was my editor in
books i was like there's only one other
thing i would write in the space
and um
she's like well what is it and
i was like well it's
it's the reason
diets don't work right
and
the answer is not physiological it it
can become physiological because it
becomes biochemical and neurological as
a side effect of repeated emotional be
emotions thoughts and behaviors which
can impact obviously your
neuroplasticity and your biochemistry
when somebody
is using food to the degree that they
become 50 pounds overweight 100 pounds
overweight it's it's an addiction like
any other addiction so there's a type of
therapy called transactional analysis
but essentially it's a decisional model
that helps to empower people over time
to make different choices and to see the
role they play and where they are now
i take umbrage with a lot of the
messaging nowadays of like you're a
victim you're a victim you're a victim
because if you're constantly telling
somebody that they are a victim
of who knows diet culture or this that
or the other even though yes at times
we've been victims and yes we've been
marginalized but if you're always giving
that message
and then you're co-signing the message
if it's okay
you're essentially disempowering someone
to make a change so
we
make these decisions
gender generally unconsciously to eat
more
or to be bigger
because at one time in our life
it meant our psychological
survival and
it could be right so it could be that
you you yes you might have been incested
molested it could be a protective layer
it could be
um part of fulfilling something called
an injunctive message so for example
let's say it's
you know the parent has their own
generational trauma right and it's like
don't be important
don't be too successful
don't be and maybe you sabotage it by
putting on the weight for those reasons
[Music]